and what a way to close out this
championship season
as you see davis and james it's all
coming out
you know one of to me one of the great
pleasures of this job every year is
watching
they become little kids again when that
title is realized
when it's finally over and all the work
all the sweat all the practices all the
travel
and in this case all this time in the
bubble
ends up with what they all set out for
as their number one and only goal
you know what each guy invested and
lebron is thinking
i promised this guy this i told him that
things would be different
and to finish it off they all should be
extremely proud
olynyk puts it up at him caruso will
bring it up
lebron james already celebrating i'm
sure they are back in los
angeles again that's why nowadays
knocks down a three-pointer there's the
exclamation point
he will just bring it up
the lakers will win game six
and now cook can just dribble it out
and j.r smith already shirtless
[Laughter]
final seconds here in this nba season
the respect from those two and that's it
it's over this historic 2020 nba
championship belongs to the los angeles
lakers
the lakers conquer the bubble and banner
number 17 will soon hang in the raptors
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
such an emotional time for these la
lakers
and also emotional for jimmy butler and
the miami heat
as we said a painful way for a great
season to come to an end
always so inspiring when an individual
or a team over achieves or accomplishes
the unexpected that's what the heat did
but they ran up against a laker team
that defensively just steamrolled him
here tonight
so much more ahead in the celebration
the trophy presentation the naming of
the finals mvp it's all ahead
as the lakers win the 2020 championship